[Applaudissements]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs ont enfin validé leur ticket
pour la nationale 3 en mai dernier en
s'imposant contre draveil à domicile
l'équipe termine première du classement
avec une seule défaite au compteur
je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits enfin c'est
vraiment vraiment une grande famille
c'est pour tout le monde voilà c'est pas
que nous on sait pas que les doux c'est
vraiment un club qui avait tout ce
moment là tous ensemble
après l'euphorie retour sur terre
plaisir se mesurer pour la première fois
une équipe de nationale 3 en coupe de
france début septembre après un match
serré les plaisirs oies sont finalement
éliminé par le club d'ici aux tirs au
but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe
réellement le profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir bas des joueurs
avec un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de jeu cette équipe
avec voilà nos qualités aujourd'hui
après quatre mois de compétition plaisir
pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat de nationale 3 3 longueurs
du leader saint paulois et ziv ils ont
notamment réalisé une série de quatre
victoires consécutives entre octobre et
novembre
l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs le fait d'avoir pris ces
quelques joueurs n'ont pas changé l'état
d'esprit du groupe
l'état d'esprit est toujours positif les
mecs sont en train de sérieusement on
s'entraîne sérieusement et donc cette
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée
maintenant on sait que ça va être dur de
la garder ma nounou battre et continuer
sur cet état d'esprit qui est pour
l'instant est repproché avec cette bande
de potes
malgré cette place de dauphin l'objectif
annoncé de cette saison 2017-2018 reste
le maintien
la montée pour le moment une question
taboue écoutez se passe on peut parler
de monter certains vous diront peut-être
que j'y pense moi aujourd'hui déjà on
prend chaque match et le groupe prend
chaque match l'un après les autres avec
l'objectif est effectivement de les
gagner
très belle année 2010 est et espérant
que l'année 2008 à eux-mêmes augure les
y reprendra officiellement la
compétition le 27 janvier prochain
l'extérieur contre chaville une victoire
et les plaisirs wa deviendraient encore
un peu plus l'équipe à suivre en 2018
dans ce championnat